russia's undeclared war against ukraine
began in 2014 when moscow sent unmarked
military forces to occupy the southern
region of crimea
and backed separatists in the eastern
part of the country
our holly williams met with ukraine's
president vladimir zelinski
he gave her a rare look at one of the
front lines in this conflict
well this trench looks like something
out of the first world war
ukrainian soldiers are on this side and
russian-backed rebel fighters are about
300 yards in that direction
but some people say that this is the
front line in a new
cold war that's brewing between russia
and the us
we hitched a ride with the ukrainian
military to a corner of europe where
lush pastures have become killing fields
we hiked past decimated villages and
through muddy trenches
with ukraine's president vladimir
zelinski
less than 150 yards from the enemy we
were warned
they could hear us they go a little bit
forward to see what's going on here
and for example at the in may
the two guys were killed by snap
this war has cost more than 13 000 lives
since it began in 2014. after protests
toppled a government that was friendly
to moscow
russia responded by sending troops to
seize control of crimea
and backing an armed insurgency in
eastern ukraine
the usa is a very long way from here why
should
ordinary americans care what's happening
here in ukraine
it can be tomorrow at their houses
you're saying if russia will do this
here i didn't know it might do it
tomorrow in the rest of europe no why
are you not
the next day attack america why not i
don't know why why not
that may sound far-fetched but experts
say
russian hackers are using ukraine as a
testing ground
including attacking the power grid
before using similar tactics in the us
and this year tens of thousands of
russian troops massed at ukraine's
border
the goal apparently to scare an american
ally
and send a threat to the west
away from the front line president
zielenski invited us for breakfast with
his
parents he grew up in this soviet-style
apartment
when ukraine was part of the ussr he
claims
president vladimir putin has imperial
ambitions
for russia to control its neighbors once
again
they don't want to make us free yes to
be the independent country
the us is supporting ukraine with money
weapons
and training but what president
zielenski really wants is america's
backing to join nato
giving his country more protection from
russia
speak about nato with us propose us we
have war
in the u.s there are fears that nato
membership for ukraine could exacerbate
tensions
but president zielinski argues that
ukraine is holding the line against
russia
and deserves more support from its
friends
many ukrainians have little hope that
the summit between presidents biden
and putin will change anything here on
the bloody
battlefield that's divided their nation
for cbs this morning holly williams
in eastern ukraine